- A lot of drunk, white people singing
about how they like barbecue
sauce, or something.
I don't know.
- I don't know any country music.
- Very, very, very vaguely
familiar with country music.
- I dated a guy once who
listened to country music.
He also drove a truck,
and had a confederate flag on his belt.
- [Long-Haired Brunette] This is Sam Hunt:
Leave the Night On.
- I've never seen a white taxi
cab driver before (laughs).
- Oh, he's sexy though.
Do all country artists look like this?
- Yeah, before I even started this,
I kind of just figured
this would be the melody
of every country song, just,
♫ ba na na na bar na ♫
- He's almost rapping.
I'm hinting, I get some
Drake flow in the end, there.
- I'm gonna Google this guy, actually,
and fall in love with him, I think.
- Who is the black guy?
Who is he?
- Oh, that voice.
(sighs) It's like nails on a chalkboard.
- They're like a boy band moves,
but like...
- (laughs) I guess that's
what white folk do,
they party in a truck.
- "This is how we roll," that's
not even a country phrase.
That's like a hip-hop phrase.
- He's using Drake hands.
These are Drake hands.
- More white people dancing!
- It's so funny.
Country music videos
are just like rap videos
in that people party in
them, they drink in them,
and there are hot girls in them.
- Oh that's fuckin' badass.
They sold me.
- [Girl in Plaid] Dierks?
Derks?
- [Long-Haired Brunette] Deerks, Deericks?
- Die-erks?
Deerks?
Deerks Bentley.
- Aww, he's heartbroken so he's
gonna get drunk on a plane.
- We had weird rave party, we
had weird truck rave party,
and I have a feeling we're gonna have
a weird country rave on this plane.
- Country music is a lot like my ex.
I really hate it, but when I'm drunk,
it's not such a bad idea.
- I like this, this is fun.
They're gettin' drunk
on a plane, I like it.
Everyone's invited to this party.
- This party's gettin'
outta hand, got it, okay.
- That was like Soul Plane,
but like white people.
- I see blonde hair that's teased,
lots of eye make-up,
eyelashes that go like that.
- At least no ones pouring
liquid on these women,
or like, putting them in front of trucks.
- I might have to add this to my iTunes.
This song is fire (laughs).
- I like them!
They're my favorite so far.
- [Long-Haired Brunette]
Country's singers are all
very beautiful in a very
nice way, I like that.
- Like, if I were to listen
to this with my eyes closed,
I would just think, "jewel heist."
- Such girls.
Go into a bank, take some pearls?
No, you take the money.
We take the gold.
- First of all, country
music's a lot happier and fun.
- I like country music now, so...
- I almost feel like country music
shouldn't have music videos.
- I feel like I could
write a country song.
- Really like that plane song.
It's about gettin' drunk on a plane.
- They know the audience
that they're playing to,
and they got it down.
- I'm here to watch some country music,
listen to some country music,
and support America.
'Merica!
It's the music of our forefathers.
This is why
they came here.